This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Norton.
Biometric scanning is the future - but how
secure is it really?
[INTRO MUSIC]
Hey guys, Tara here for DNews and with all
the recent technology made in biometric scanning,
you might be wondering - what is the actual
risk involved in using these devices?
And is it really impossible for someone to steal
my identity through them?
The short answer is no - it's not impossible.
But it is significantly trickier.
It's helpful to think of your fingerprint
in the same way you think of a credit card:
it's really just a string of numbers run
through a computer network.
The difference is, unlike credit card numbers or passwords, your fingerprint can't be lost or misplaced.
But it also can't be changed once it gets
stolen. And that's where the real security issue comes in.
When you consider that all of that information
is stored in a database somewhere, then that's
what the hackers will target. And assuming
there's encryption involved, once that information
gets stolen, there are tons of ways to take
advantage of it.
Many of the companies that manufacture fingerprint
scanners like to claim that their technology is unbreakable.
But as the Mythbusters proved back in 2006,
all it takes to steal one is a little bit of dedication.
In their episode, they successfully
cracked a scanner using three different methods.
The first time, they copied someone's fingerprint
onto a latex glove and then used that to open a door.
The second time, they managed to create
a copy of a fingerprint using ballistics gel,
which is just gelatin mixed with water. And
the third time, all it took was a photocopy
of someone's fingerprint and a little bit
of saliva.
You may also remember how Apple's iPhone
5S, which came with a Touch ID fingerprint
scanner built in was hacked by researchers
just one day after it launched.
Scientists managed to crack it using a cheap domestic
scanner to create a photograph of a print
left on the glass screen. Granted, it was not
an easy process,  but for the criminally inclined
who have a lot of time on their hands, it's
still doable.
So what about eye scanners? Lots of companies
are currently dabbling in both retina and
iris scanners, but how do they work, and
how secure are they?
Retina scanners work by shooting an invisible
infrared light into your eyeball and measuring
the pattern of light that gets reflected back
which is unique for every person.
Unfortunately some diseases, like glaucoma and diabetes, can change that pattern over time, potentially
locking you out of your own devices.
Iris scanners work in a similar way
in that they shoot near-infrared light into
your eye and use the light that reflects back
to replicate the intricacies of your iris.
For the most part, it's considered superior
to retina scanning. It can be done from a
greater distance, so it's less intrusive.
And your iris isn't susceptible to disease
in the same way your retina is
so unless you suffer from a serious eye injury, it'll pretty much remain the same throughout your life.
As far as biometric scanning goes, the iris
appears to be the "final frontier"
so we shouldn't be surprised if our phones
start coming with that technology built in,
even a few years from now.
Of course, it still brings up the same issues
as any fingerprint scanning. If the information
is stored somewhere, it's naturally vulnerable
to theft. And once it gets stolen, it's
pretty much stolen forever.
Fortunately, there's already software out
there to protect you from identity theft and
other dangers online, so a big thank you
to Norton for protecting the vulnerable among
us and for sponsoring the show.
In the meantime, let us know what you think
about the future of biometric scanning, in
the comments down below, and as always, thank
you guys for watching!
This episode of DNews was brought to you by Norton.